>>
What the question of role models important
in the Middle East? Absolutely. I'm particularly
concerned about the role models for women
and girls in the Middle East. Because it's
really important to have what I call the power
of the mirror, knowing what it is you can
be by who it is you see. I'll tell you a little
story. When I met the president of Iceland.
She had been the president of Iceland for
16 years. But she said to me that after she
was president for about eight years, she was
going around Iceland, she was talking to the
children. One of the things she discovered
was the children under eight, they all thought
only a woman could be president of Iceland.
That the boys had to ask if they could be
president of Iceland, because they had never
seen it. That's what I call the power in the
mirror. And I think particularly for the development
of the economy within the Middle East or the
development of political process, the advancement
of the girls and women in the Middle East,
I think is essential. And progress is being
made, but we need to figure out how to hurry
history. And one of the ways I think we can
do that is by having more and more women as
role models. Young girls can see that they
can be many things when they grow up.